Here are some guidelines about the review process itself. First off,
spread out the reviews over time.
Performance degrades if reviews are too concentrated. A practical limit for
the duration of a review is the smaller of 250 lines of code, or 2 hours of,
of artifact reviewing. Each type of review should have its own criterion for
thoroughness, which should be determined in advance of the meeting.
You can, treat the review as a go, no go decision activity. That is,
the review meeting should end with a decision about whether or
not the artifact is ready for the next stage of the development process.
In fact, some organizations require the reviewers to sign off on
the acceptability of the artifact, thereby improving accountability.